The area that I grew up in.
Sometimes a gun is the only way to protect yourself.
Yeah,
anti gun.
You don't,
you don't want nobody to have guns.
But then that's going to put my family at dangerous.
The pull to the left.
I'm going to have all my pro gun people go stand on the edge of that light and
all my anti gun people on the other side.
First statement is I think my views on guns could change.
Oh,
I felt like anyone's views can change on things,
so I'm kind of surprised that nobody felt like it could change at all.
They don't think that I could change completely the other side,
but I would definitely be open to like looking at it from a different
perspective.
I think that my stance is very accommodating to both sides.
That said,
I feel really solid about kind of the what I've learned and what I think is
possible.
So I feel really solid about that.
Although I'm,
you know,
open to accommodating for people's needs,
people's wishes with their rights.
My name is Aaron Clayton.
After the Orlando shooting,
I realized that my community was very much a target.
I had to get involved to do something.
Sometimes I think people on the other side of the issue don't care about me or
my loved ones lives.
I got to go with that one.
Got to go with that one at the scene.
Um,
I mean,
the area that I grew up in and why I come from a lot of,
you may not be able to understand that sometimes a gun is the only way to
protect yourself and we all believed there should be certain rules to,
to getting them.
But on my side of the earth,
there is no gun laws.
My Name is Sandy Hill.
Regardless of whatever you say,
there's always going to be,
guns is always going to be violence in the world.
And I got family protect.
Yeah.
I don't think y'all don't care about me or my family,
you know?
I think we all care about each other and each other's lives.
Others,
you know,
loved ones
I don't care about.
Yeah.
I'm trying to protect me in mind.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my reason of saying that nobody else cares about it because I'm pretty
sure y'all have the same insight.
Like you're anti gun,
you don't,
you don't want nobody to have guns.
But then that's going to put my family at danger.
I don't want,
that's not at all.
I think that that's is how I feel like the pro con people,
a lot of times they're like,
well it's never going to be solved like don and never going to end and like it
won't and you're absolutely correct,
but there's a bunch of ways to decrease it.
I've been in a situation in which my life
was in danger.
I grew up in Saint Louis,
so we'd go downtown where is a huge amount of violence.
We are home depot and this guy's starting to gather around my dad's truck and
I'm in it alone.
I'm 14 years old and let it just,
I had to pull my gun out while I'm shaking and Lou just set it on my lap and to
show that it ended up potentially violent,
potentially robbery,
you know,
I don't think people automatically are born or like I'm pro guide.
Like I think what you experienced in your life makes you that way.
My name is Sarah.
It wasn't until recently that my opinion changed on how I felt about guns and
then I became program in order to protect me and my future family.
I was never programmed before and then some guy broke into my place and rate me
and I couldn't run away.
I can do anything like literally had the lay there and take it,
but I knew that if I had a gun at that point in time on my nightstand,
I've would've defended myself.
I think America has a problem with mass shootings.
I think we all should step forward for that one.
Cool.
It'd be ignorant to say it's not an issue.
Like I don't want anyone to die.
Like I don't want to see these school shootings.
I don't want people to get hurt.
We're all for protecting ourselves.
But I think like when guns are not in the right hands,
then it becomes an issue.
And I don't think any west support that at the end of the day.
So you all for like stricter gun laws or no,
I mean there's a point where it goes too far.
I don't think I need to take a 5,000 question questionnaire for a psychological
tests,
you know,
like isn't that worth it?
And like I'm not saying that that's necessarily what we would definitely do or
whatever,
but like a 5,000 questionnaire or like people's lives.
But it sounds like,
wouldn't you rather,
would you be willing to go through the same process to get an automobile
training,
licensing,
renewable licensing?
Yeah.
But not a psychological test.
I think it doesn't have to be so extensive,
which you're saying,
but it's sad how someone can come into a gun show and have a lot of money,
buy whatever they want.
So a little,
maybe a little card or something and get like maybe 20 guns and no one's asking
you just because you have money.
A simple back brown check can just do a lot for people.
But I also think that a lot of people like because they don't want to have the
conversation about gun violence and they switch over and say like,
oh it's mental illness and like that needs to be talked about too.
But gun violence is a separate issue that also like really needs to be talked
about.
If my life was in danger,
I would kill hell.
Yeah.
Can I walk fast?
No,
I really don't think I would have like in,
I don't know
if I would have nobody,
nobody has it in them until the moment comes.
Like literally fear doesn't even become a thing anymore.
Like it disappears and it's like fight or flight.
Yeah.
Like in you either freeze and die or you make it.
And after that end of the day,
I'm going to make it,
some people don't got it.
Then you can always just,
you know,
shoot him in a place where they won't be able to move.
That's what some people think of.
When I went to,
uh,
I did my carrying conceal class,
they said,
if you're trying to shoot him in the leg,
you have enough time to get away or,
or to realize you're not in danger.
Your life is in danger,
you know?
And so they said,
you know,
if you're pulling a gun out and you're shooting somebody,
you're shooting to kill.
I guess I just,
I don't understand.
I understand fighting for your life.
That's why I came to this,
to the center for sure.
But like all this talk about like how to protect ourselves,
how to be in these situations,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
again,
we're just increasing guns and I,
I keep just one,
I want to bring us back to like,
how can we combat this from the other end?
I don't want to carry guns.
I don't want to have guns in my club.
I don't want to,
I want to be there to dance.
I don't want to have a firearm on my leg.
And like he was trying to society.
So you rather just not have one.
I know,
I don't think we can track from that.
Other countries have done that,
but you're taking the right away.
But if I can prove to you that there are ways to enact gun reform that will
decrease the amount of guns out there,
increase education and not hurt the ability of law abiding citizens to have
access to firearms,
would you be willing to discuss ways to do that?
Yeah,
I'm all,
like I said,
I'm all for education,
but I don't think like at the end of the day,
like if someone's trying to kill me,
I'm going to kill them.
But that is you're allowed to right now you're allowed to have that gun.
And so we keep kind of saying what we're is already in place.
This is already possible to have all of these guns.
Like how can we start looking at this and you know,
changing our minds and our Congress,
our government,
you know,
leaders' minds,
you guys keep talking about education,
but that is not a reality and that we're not allowed to instill reform.
That gives us gun education.
So it's just like layman's ideas,
batting around ideas on how to kill,
how to kill.
I'm overall against violence at the end of the day.
Um,
I wouldn't need or want to have a gun if there wasn't violence in the world,
but sometimes it's a right because it's a nest necessity sometimes.
So how do we change,
how do we do that where we start changing the conversation where people don't
immediately relate pro gun to uh,
or don't eat that program can equal pro gun reform.
Oh,
I mean that's why we're all here.
That's why we're all here.
We're all risking something by saying something.
I'll always taught that.
Don't
ever,
um,
like state your opinion on hot topics because you're just asking for it at that
point.
But I feel like you have to speak up cause being silent as being just as guilty.
I think the society needs to learn to speak like educated people need to sit
down and come together and talk about things.
You guys have something to say and we said it and we accept all of each other's
views.
I told her,
we will not leave hating each other.
Art or boy does it right.
I'm Taylor.
Nice to meet you.
Uh,
we disagree sometimes and it's okay because this is middle ground.
This is a middle ground.
We hope you guys liked it and we hope that we can continue to bridge people
together through videos like this.
Please let us know in the comments,
uh,
what side you fall on and what your thoughts are.
Tell us why you believe what you believe.
Yup.
Jubilee.
Yes.
And if you want to see any more middle ground episodes,
will let us know what you want to see.
Cause you guys,
you have the best ideas.
What you guys think.
Cool.
And until next time,
subscribe and we'll see you guys later.
Perfect.
High Five.